Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call any time of day.
The number is two one nine two.
David P. Here is a really interesting voicemail
about this continued topic of the anti council
culture.
Republicans canceling one of their own, not
a very big tent is what it's seeming like.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: I do, you know, the the right that
has a very large tent that doesn't cancel
anybody, like extreme people like Lauren Bovver.
Yeah.
And that gate that will be canceled because
they don't believe in castle culture.
The one encompass all sorts of different voices.
However, after canceling Liz Cheney from the
Castle Cultural Rights, have a question.
Do you think Liz Cheney can come back twice
as strong and cancel the crap out of the Republican
Party?
What is she going to do?
I don't think she's going to go quietly.
Seriously is she's going to become a Democrat?
No, she's very conservative.
But what can she do to get them back?
I have a hunch we have not seen the last of
Liz Cheney.
I'm actually rooting for her.
No problem, brother.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I agree that Liz Cheney won't
go quietly, but I'm skeptical that there's
much she can do.
And the reason I say that is the party of
the Republican Party is still completely under
the control of Trump and Trump ism.
In fact, the cancelation of Liz Cheney is
further evidence of that.
We've been wondering, will they go pro Trump
or anti Trump going into 2022?
Will they go more in the direction of Cheney
and Romney, or are they going to go more in
the direction of Bobert, Marjorie Taylor Green,
Madison Cawthorn, Louie Gohmert, Jim Jordan,
Elise Stefanik, cetera?
And the cancelation of Liz Cheney to me is
evidence that they're going with the Trump
side.
70 percent of the voters still believe Trump
actually won two thirds of the Republican
voters, that 70 percent of Republican voters,
two thirds of Republican voters claimed they'd
follow Trump to another party.
They are choosing to get rid of Liz Cheney
for something from leadership.
She's still in the House for something as
seemingly uncontroversial as what should be
uncontroversial of just saying, oh, the election
results are the results and Trump lost shouldn't
be even should shouldn't even be anything.
And yet she is losing her leadership role
because of that.
So while I agree that Liz Cheney does not
seem like the type to just go quietly, I am
unsure about what she actually will be able
to do substantively because this party seems
to have gone fully in with Trump for twenty
twenty two as of what we're seeing for the
for the in the immediate, if you see it differently,
let me know.
But that's the way it's looking to me.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
A homeless man has been awarded one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars as a judge has
tossed out St. Louis County anti panhandling
ordinances.
This is very interesting and the precedent
that it sets could be meaningful and long
lasting in terms of how we criminalize homelessness
in many parts of the country.
Number two, a judge has dismissed the NRA
bankruptcy case, making it more likely the
NRA may be dissolved.
Cautious optimism there.
And we will also talk about New York City
mayoral candidate Andrew Yang now in hot water
with a bunch of different people over a tweet
he sent about the Israeli-Palestinian conflict,
followed by a letter he put out this morning,
will explain all of it and discuss the implications.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
How do you get the bonus show?
A lot of people are wondering and the answer
remains very simple.
Sign up at join Pakman Dotcom.
That's it.
It's cheap.
It's quick.
It's easy.
You support the show.
And if you would like a discount off of that
membership to hear our takes on all of these
extra stories, use the coupon code better.
Twenty one, you save big, you get 100 percent
of the benefits at a major discount.
Join Pakman Dotcom.
We'll see everybody on the boat.